[music playing]
[motor revving]
JASON SILVA: What
does it take to power
a global civilization
to connect billions
of people across continents?
It takes the power
of transportation.
From the beginning,
speed and strength
were paramount in the
hunt, on the battle field,
for holding together
far-flung empires.
We sought new forms of power,
harnessing the forces of nature
to drive us forward--
the horse, the wheel,
steam power, jet engine.
Every new innovation
powered our next great leap.
Transportation has become
our exoskeleton allowing
us to transcend our biology.
[music playing]
Faster than sound,
farther than the moon,
our inventions give us a level
of power we never imagined.
With our machines we carved
through solid rock, tunneled
beneath the sea floor,
connecting the world,
mixing distant cultures.
Freedom of movement has
given us freedom of mind.
The flow of people and materials
exposes us to new ideas
and new understanding.
This is the story of how
transportation turned society
inside out, how engines and
animals powered the rise
of civilization, and how the
innovations that drive humanity
forward made us modern.
This is "Origins."